you beautifully put
that the thing that drew you to fighter
jets is the technology so if you were to
think
to imagine from an alien perspective
what kind of technologies would we first
encounter as human beings
if we were to meet another alien
civilization
in the next few centuries
what kind of thing would we see so
you're now at the cutting edge and you
see the quick progress that's happening
that was happening throughout the 20th
century that's happening now with
greater degrees of autonomy with robots
and that kind of stuff what do you think
we will encounter
i think we're going to see
the ability to manipulate matter like we
used to manipulate information like i
think that's what
whether that means
being able to
pop something on the table that didn't
exist or to
influence a chemical reaction somewhere
but being able to manipulate and
treat matter as if it was information
and so being able to design specific
materials being able to
move past a lot of the barriers that
seem to limit our progress with things
such as miniaturized fusion or even just
fusion in general
is you know a lot of it is is
matter-based as material-based and our
ability to not
manipulate we can only discover
materials in a sense and so i think that
a complete mastery of the physical
reality would be one of the key traits
of a very intelligent species
you